it's a Tuesday edition of PFT p.m.
recording a little bit early today just
because I want to articulate some
thoughts about the Patrick mahomes
contract I've written about this if pro
football talk comm I want to explain in
further detail why I believe what I
believe about the mahomes contract and
my broad belief is he shouldn't sign it
and Patrick if you're listening and the
chances that you're listening or slim
and none if you haven't signed it yet
don't sign it a 12-year commitment is
way too long of a contract for a player
of his skill and ability to sign I'm
talking to you now not him I've given up
on talking to him because I know he's
not listening but here's the bottom line
he's the best player in football right
now potentially potentially the best
player of all time we'll find out in the
coming years and in the coming 12 years
the Chiefs have exclusive control over
his rights he can't get out for 12 years
he can't force his way back to the table
over the course of the next 12 years
sure he can hold out at some point he
doesn't seem like the type that would
hold how but he could because to a point
where he looks around in 2027 20 28 and
realizes that that contract with a new
money average of 45 million dollars per
year pales in comparison to somebody we
haven't even heard of yet who may be
making 60 million per year at the time
and the salary cap may be north of 300
million maybe 400 million per year at
the time there's too much uncertainty
over the way the game is going to change
over the way the money is going to grow
and in some respects the Chiefs got him
at a perfect time because right now the
uncertainty skews negative we're looking
at the pandemic we don't know what's
going to happen we don't know when
things are gonna be normal again well at
some point they will be and when they
are normal there will be plenty of
people spending plenty of money and
plenty of time watching football and as
states throughout the country try to
repair their budgets after the pandemic
the reality is this
there will be legalized gambling
coast-to-coast there will be exceptions
Utah
beyond that hell maybe even you table
will give in and allow legalized
gambling because that's a way to make
back a lot of money and everyone's
losing money state and federal
governments are losing money and
everyone else for the most part is
losing money during this pandemic the
legalized gambling will spread more
money will be made by the NFL more money
will be made by the teams everything
will get larger and larger and larger
and larger
except pad from homes contract ten-year
450 million dollar extension 12-year 477
million dollar contract think about that
for a second it's not a half billion
dollar deal it's not I may be the only
person in the media who will say to you
it's not a half billion dollar deal for
70 78 post it's not a half billion it
gets to a half billion with 25 million
in incentives two and a half million per
year spread out over ten years and we
don't know what it takes
yet to the two and a half million maybe
it's easy maybe he's got to be the MVP
of the league or the Super Bowl MVP
every year to get the two and a half
million we don't know I just feel like
somebody wanted to say here's a half
billion dollar contract the first half
billion dollar contract in all of sports
the problem is by the time we get to the
second half of the contract there's a
good chance Patrick mahomes is gonna be
feeling some regret there's a good
chance he's going to be feeling like
he's not being paid fairly and if push
comes to shove there's nothing he can do
about it and see the problem is before
you even get to the point where you
complain about this deal you have to be
willing to acknowledge to the world
maybe I should have signed the deal
that's the first hurdle see that that's
that's the genius of this deal that's
why the Chiefs employees were out
looking for champagne yesterday this is
a great deal for them and this is a deal
that there's a good chance Pat mahomes
will never say I have regrets over it
even if he does think about and I this
is the John voids car example remember
the song I felt episode where the
George Costanza decision was made to buy
the car that was owned by Jon Voight and
there was a question as to whether or
not it was really Jon Voight the actor
and and he kept doubling down and
digging in because he didn't want to
look foolish see players will be
inclined to double down and dig in on
contracts that they shouldn't have
signed because the first step is to
admit maybe I shouldn't have done this
and I'm telling you he should have done
it no great player should sign a 12-year
contract there's no reason to do it
because you quickly get to the point in
the life of the contract where it's a
one-way deal we talk about this all the
time the team has the right to rip it up
anytime they want the player has no
right to rip it up the player is stuck
the team isn't now the guarantee
mechanisms a word that had never been
used before in the 20 years I've been
covering the NFL basically a series of
roster bonuses built into the contract
every year good move forces the Chiefs
to make an early decision instead of
squatting on Pat mahomes until September
they have to make a decision in March
every year nothing wrong with that but
that first of all it's not guaranteed
money 477 million in guarantee
mechanisms all that means is there's a
roster bonus every year that versus the
Chiefs to make a decision early and if
the decision is we no longer think that
his skills and abilities justify what
we're supposed to pay him that's when he
gets cut and that's when he has to go
out and find something else that's when
he becomes a free agent but the reality
is he only becomes a free agent if his
play has diminished to the point where
the Chiefs look at what they're due to
pay him and they say he's not worth this
anymore
so if he's not worth that to the Chiefs
he's not gonna be worth that to anybody
else there's no reason to do a 12-year
deal it really isn't and I'm trying to
understand why he agreed to it
my advice to Patrick mahomes would have
been this wait you're due to make 27.6 3
million over the next two years
wait franchise tag exclusive franchise
tag which is what surely would be
extended to my homes come early 2022
would be well north of 30 million
dollars this year for dak Prescott the
exclusive tag 31.4
in two years it may be 35 maybe more
wait 20% raise over that for 2023 44
percent raise over that for 2024 wait
add up those numbers for 2021 also 2020
the twenty seven point six three million
for the next two years three years of
the tag five years do that math that's
what you're reasonably looking at
getting barring some sort of an injury
that derails your career and causes the
Chiefs not to exercise the franchise tab
on top of that you've got great
endorsement money that's coming in the
the best player in the NFL one was
popular players in the NFL endorsements
out Bo wazoo
for Patrick mahomes that's one of the
reasons that Prescott has waited his
endorsement portfolio you get an
insurance policy to protect you against
the career-ending injury now look the
the problem with insurance policies like
that are number one they're very
expensive but number two good luck
trying to get the money when it's time
to cash in because it has to be a truly
career-ending injury those don't happen
very often two quarterbacks and then you
can try to get a loss of value policy
where you would argue well the contract
I eventually got was worth a lot less
than it would have been good luck
proving that to see the profit insurance
companies is this their commodity is
money so they want to take in as much
money as they can and they want to pay
out as little money as they can that's
their commodity they have no products
they have no goods it's money
let's take in as much as we can let's
pay out as little as we can and the last
thing they want to do is pay out these
gigantic policies that go to
professional athletes but still still it
gives you protection against a truly
catastrophic outcome that prevents you
from ever playing again so you look at
the bird in the hand you look at your
path year to year under the franchise
tag you look at your endorsement money
you have faith in your ability to
continue to play at a high level and you
just wait now what's he getting return
for that he's traded in twenty seven
point six three million plus his ability
to go year to year under the franchise
tag for a contract that pays out 63
million fully guaranteed at signing
or 1 million more fully guarantee they
want Ryan Tannehill got on a four-year
contract with the Tennessee Titans is 63
million fully guaranteed at signing
enough to justify a 12 year commitment
the easy answer to that question is no
way in hell it's not it never is
so I'm still trying to understand why
this was done and there's some
speculation in leaf circles that Leigh
Steinberg who isn't known currently
although maybe he currently now is as a
high-level quarterback contract
negotiator there's some concern that if
they had waited two years to do the
mahomes deal maybe
mahomes decides to jump to another
agency maybe after CAA gets a mega deal
for dak Prescott mahomes says I think
I'd like them to do my deal or if the
Shaun Watson gets a great deal from the
Texans a 3-year deal that pays him a ton
of money but gets him back to the trough
sooner rather than later
maybe mahomes decides to go to athletes
first maybe after Russell Wilson gets
his next deal mahomes decides that he's
going to hire the baseball agent - hey I
played baseball mark Rogers the baseball
agent with one client has done a great
work for Russell Wilson getting him to
markets setting deals
maybe I'll maybe I'll hire him that's a
real dynamic
I mean I'm gonna peel the curtain back
that's a very real dynamic for agents
they're always worried about someone
stealing their clients and if somebody
would come in and get Patrick mahomes to
go sign with them or even if mahomes
just decides on his own I'm gonna go
with someone else you don't make any
future money now Leigh Steinberg and his
firm are fully vested in whatever
percentage they're getting of that 477
million over the next 12 years it's a
nice annuity payment that's a nice
that's a nice check that arrives - every
year from Patrick mahomes under this
deal that pays out 45 million per year
in new money on the 10-year extension so
just something to think about
just just part of the reality of the
agent business in the National Football
League doing the deal now locks in the
fee for 12 years waiting for two years
runs the risk that someone else may end
up being the one who does the long-term
deal for Patrick mahomes there's plenty
of other angles and plenty of other
wrinkles and things that I haven't even
thought about yet that I'll think about
at some point and I'll either write
about it or we'll talk about it again
tomorrow but but but seriously this
isn't a criticism of Patrick mahomes he
hired the agents to do the deal you have
to defer to your agents they're the
doctor they're the expert you need to
trust them I just don't know how you
reconcile the talent that Patrick Homes
has with a 12-year commitment that puts
the full control in the hands of the
team beyond the first couple of years
there's no reason to do this none
whatsoever
well he wants to stay in Kansas City
well that's fine he can want to stay in
Kansas City but Kansas City has don't
want him this is not a two-way
commitment Kansas City you can say we're
done with you at any time after we get
past the first couple years you know
what even then the cap hits aren't that
significant if something happened look
it's likely not going to happen
but the Chiefs have full flexibility
they have full control they decide how
long this lasts this is not something
that secures Patrick mahomes future in
Kansas City it secures kids a city's
future with Patrick mahomes for as long
as they wanted up to 12 years that's why
they bought that champagne yesterday
folks what does this mean for dak
Prescott I put the question out on
Twitter today what the Cowboys offer dak
Prescott the pack from a homes deal
right now and if so would Patrick
mahomes deal be accepted by dak Prescott
I have to let you know Macy's just
walked into the room I thought the door
was closed so she's in here sniffing
around there's a chance you'll see her
she's under the desk right now she
thinks I may have dropped some food I
may have dropped some potato chips last
night so we're just going to keep this
rolling this is a new experience Maisie
can you please move there she's finally
moved you may see her in the background
there she is I can see her back there
anyway and she and I don't think she's
been out to use the bathroom today so
there's a chance she may bark at some
point but with that Prescott I don't
believe
he would take this deal for one very
obvious reason he's not going to commit
for 12 years he'd much rather take I
believe the Ryan Tannehill contract for
years 118 million by the way Tannehill
over the next four years gonna make more
impact mahomes Tannehill got 62 million
fully guaranteed at signing
mahomes got 63 million fully 214 at
signing I think between the two deals
Dec would take Tannehill over my homes
we know DAC only wants to do a four year
deal so what does this mean for dak
Prescott look it Altima means nothing
because
Prescott's got 34 point note 31 point 4
million in hand for this year 37.6 made
8 million in hand for next year if they
tagged him again and then the
opportunity to hit the open market or
get a 44 percent raise for 2022
I've been saying all along the Cowboys
have to offer him something that will
get him to trade in what he could make
this year next year and come 2022
whether they tagged him again at a 44
percent raise or they let it become a
free agent
patro mahomes deal means nothing to dak
Prescott now here's the problem because
the best player in football has done
this 12 year deal what's going to happen
to these other quarterbacks they're
gonna have to deal with this comparison
you're gonna hear that teams will be
saying to players well you're no Patrick
mahomes what makes you think you deserve
a better deal than he got we want you to
sign a 12-year deal it was good enough
from a Homes it should be good enough
for you now that's that's probably not
gonna work but it complicates life for
the agents who are trying to negotiate
these long term deals for quarterbacks
moving forward 12 years should not
become the norm
the deals need to be shorter especially
as we move toward a world where
everything is going to increase it's
hard to see past the pandemic but there
is a future beyond a pandemic and once
we get there the numbers are gonna go up
and whether he admits it or not
Patrick mahomes is going to regret
having signed a deal that commits him to
the Chiefs for 12 years but doesn't
commit the Chiefs to him for 12 years
DeSean Jackson's in the news for a
ridiculously anti-semitic post that he
put on social media I'm not going to
quote it I don't even want to say much
about it I'm just flabbergasted that
something that ridiculously wrong would
end up on social media the question is
this what are the Eagles gonna do about
now when Riley Cooper was videotaped
using a slur back in 2013-14 time frame
early in the Chip Kelly tenure in
Philadelphia they found a way to move
forward which surprised me because
frankly Riley Cooper wasn't good enough
of a player to justify finding a way to
move forward but they got Mike Vick
involved he smooth things over in the
locker room there were guys like LeSean
McCoy who wanted Riley Cooper out and
once the Eagles were done with Cooper he
never could find footing anywhere else
DeSean Jackson falls into a category
right now in his career where he's not
good enough to justify the trouble and
we know this is how it works
for football great players key players
you find a way to work with them you
don't want their Redemption to come with
one of your arch rivals lesser players
you make an example out of them now I
think the right thing to do for this
kind of hatred in this moment for that
kind of ridiculous anti-semitic talk in
this moment the right thing to do is
sever ties regardless of who it is it's
an easier analysis for the Eagles
because it's a guy who's on the downward
slope is of his career
they got nothing out of him last year
although what they got in week 1 against
Washington and I remember talking to
Carson Wentz after that game Jackson's
abilities the two long touchdown passes
that he scored helped turn around a game
that was going the wrong way for
Philadelphia and until they know how
their rookie first rounder is gonna work
out maybe mitt maybe you know Jackson's
in that bet that no man's land between
obviously you get rid of him and
obviously you find a way to work it out
with him my preference would be for this
kind of hatred in this moment that there
should be no tolerance for it and there
should be a significant consequence but
the reality is this I I don't think
DeSean Jackson is canceled there's gonna
be somebody out there if the Eagles move
on from DeSean Jackson once he makes the
proper atonement and he
already trying taken out of context
misconstrued it's like Charles Barkley
saying he was misquoted in his own
autobiography there's a point where you
can't say that what you said isn't what
you meant to say but at some point he'll
get that second chance especially this
year with the likelihood that plenty of
players will end up on the kovat 19 list
as this virus inevitably spreads through
locker rooms practice fields game fields
etc so that's the analysis the Eagles
have to engage in and their owners
Jewish and their general managers Jewish
and we'll see how they react to the
ridiculously anti-semitic thoughts that
were put on social media by DeSean
Jackson we may do a second pft p.m.
later today with an update for now the
Eagles haven't said anything I assume
that they'll be saying something sooner
rather than later last point before we
go and again like I said there is a very
good chance that we may do another
segment later today the NFLPA in the NFL
careening toward impasse when it comes
to some of the key protocols that will
apply for practicing and playing in a
pandemic JC Trevor the NFLPA president
has posted a new item at the NFLPA
website I haven't had a chance to write
about it yet at Pro Football Talk but it
is obvious that there are issues it is
obvious there is disagreement and it is
obvious that the Union is trying to put
pressure on the NFL to ensure that the
circumstances for a return to practice
and a return to play are as safe as they
possibly can be for the players but
here's the fundamental problem with the
Union faces and this was illustrated by
comments from Buccaneers tackle Ali
Marquette
- Joe Buck's fan calm wrote about this
earlier today in the same set of
comments Mark said well you know it may
be that the NFL PA doesn't recommend
that players play this year based upon
whatever it is the NFL wants to do okay
fine
in that same exchange mark Pett pointed
out that the recommendation from the NFL
PA that players shouldn't engage in
group activities until training camp
being ignored by his own teammates like
Tom Brady that that's no big deal
because there's no enforcement there
that's just a recommendation well here's
the problem if guys like Tom Brady are
going to ignore the recommendation by
the NFLPA to not engage in group
workouts before training camp do you
think they're going to heed any
recommendation by the NFLPA to not show
up for training camp do you think
they're going to heed any recommendation
by the NFLPA not to play games if they
try to launch a wildcat strike over
concerns that the NFL isn't providing a
sufficiently safe workplace will it play
out like a strike where everyone is in
solidarity and walks off the job and
stays off the job and gets the NFL to
buckle or will it be some guys leave
some guys stay in the NFL happily finds
guys who can walk right through the door
and take the place of the ones who leave
and the thing just keeps rolling what do
you think it'll be based upon the
history of NFL players strikes go back
to 1987 Macy's making noises back there
they brought in replacement players and
the players came they came back now the
NFL doesn't want it to come to that I
think the NFL is trying to cooperate
with the players for one very important
reason they want the players to buy in
completely to the safety protocols they
want the players to be conscientious
about not getting infected they want the
players to do the right things when they
go home they want the players to not be
going out to restaurants and bars
that'll be easier in the states where
the bars are closed but in the states
where the bars are open you want the
players to make good decisions if your
players are upset if your players are
pissed off maybe they will be inclined
to engage in riskier behaviors that
could bring the virus into the facility
and could cause the season to collapse
upon itself I think that's what the
NFL's trying to do that's the challenge
for the league because if it comes down
to a wildcat strike it ain't gonna be
all that wide because most of the cats
are going to decide to either not leave
in the first place or come back once
others are brought in to play the
challenge is making sure everyone does
everything they're supposed to do to
keep the virus out of the facility and
off
of the fields so there isn't the kind of
outbreak among multiple teams that
forces teams to shut down and that
ultimately forces the league to shut
down that's the challenge that's why the
NFL is working with the NFLPA and the
clock is ticking it's time to reach some
decisions so the coaches will know what
the rules are and can plan accordingly
so the general managers will know what
the rules are and can plan accordingly
and so people will be able to show up
for work
rookies on June 21 rest of the team or
July 21 excuse me rest of the team on
July 28 it's already July 7 there isn't
much time to get this done here's hoping
that it does alright that's it for this
morning's edition of pft p.m. based upon
the developments throughout the course
of the day we may do something later on
until then check us out all day long at
Pro Football Talk comm we'll talk to you
again soon
you